Bunun ne anlama geldiğini bilen var
mı Üniversite öğrencileri ellerini
Kaldırabilir mi bir ben üniversitedeyken
öğrendim de adımdan daha çok okuyordum
bunu çok fazla dersten kalıyordum Yani
bir kısmını geçiyordum açılınca ferin
arasından diğer harfleri bulmaya
çalışıyordum E bir ara 23 dersten
kaldım ve 23 ders bir yıl içinde Alman
lazımdı Okulu bitirmem için uzatacaktır
Ama yine de çok uzatmamak için yani
eee ve oturdum dedim ki Tamam
çalışacağım interneti eve bağlatmıyor
Eee ve nasıl yapacağım dedim ki şimdi
çalışsam E bir ay sonra unuturum ne
çalıştığımı Çünkü aldığın dersleri Say
diyordu arkadaşlar böyle Parmaklarım
yetmiyordu işte elektromanyetik alanlar
elektronik devre teorisi diferansiyel
denklemler Bir de böyle Baba dersler
dedim dedim ki Eee şöyle bir şey yapayım
internette görmüştüm biri video çekip
anlatıyordu öyle bir şey yapabilirim
Çünkü benim çok ciddi bir dikkat
dağınıklı sorunum var Yani ben o dersin
başına oturduğumda Aklımın % 199'u
internette
oluyordu ve dedim ki işte böyle video
çekeyim hem Video çekerken korkuyorsunuz
yani çeken var mı bilmiyorum da çünkü
Onu izleyenler yorum yapacak ve YouTube
yorumcuları dünyanın en şey yorumcuları
Sert
Mesela bir olayı anlatayım bir tane 36
dakikalık video çekmiştim 6 dakikadan
sonra ses yok ben var Sanıyorum sonra
biri gelmiş Demiş ki Hocam 6 dakikadan
sonra ses yok Sonra biri gelmiş Demiş ki
Hocam 6 dakikadan sonra Premium
versiyonu nasıl alabiliriz sonra biri de
gelmiş Demiş ki dininiz imanınız para
olmuş sonra ben açtım ses 30 dakika boşa
konuşmuş küfür
yemişim elim Tamam Eee başladım Sonra
kaydettim arkadaşlara verdim nasıl olmuş
falan Sonra YouTube'a Yükledim çok fazla
isteyen oldu Sonra arkadaşlar
Facebook'tan dedi ki ya Bura matematik
videosu çeksene hani ona ihtiyacımız var
yani biz elektromanyetik alanları Ne
yapalım Ondan sonra matematik videosu
çekmeye başladım Çünkü önümde KPSS vardı
Ve bu kanala videolar yükledim kanal
büyüdü büyüdü işte E o zaman para
kazanmı olduk YouTube Yani tamamen
gönüllüyü Sonra işte bir ayda bir ev
kirası kadar para getirmeye başladı
Kanal işte 45.000 aboneye çıktı şu an 10
milyona yakın izlenme var kanalda yani
Google adamı yazınca yanda üstlü sayılar
çıkıyor
E çok kötü bir şey değil diye
düşünüyorum Eee ve kanalı şey yaparken
videoları böyle zorluklarda yaşıyorsunuz
bir iki tanesi böyle anlamlı bir gün
diferansiyel denklem çözüyorum
anneannemle kal alıyorduk rahmetliye
şimdi zor bir soru e ve ben o dersi
zaten 4 kez alıyorum E anne annem
içeriden diyor ki Buğra ben çözüyorum
zorlanıyorum Buğra Buğra biren girdi en
sonunda Buğra yemek hazır dedi video
gitti zaten zorlanarak çözüyorum bir
kere kondansatör boşalıyor yerine yine
yanlış demeyeyim diye dikkat ediyorum
kondansatör boşalıyor yerine boşanıyor
demişim bütün okul kondansatörü boşayan
adam olarak bilmeye başladı ve Ama iyi
gitti işte Şu an YouTube kanalı böyle
girebilirsiniz bur diye Hobi olarak
yaptım 3 yıldır video çekmiyorum ama
başka şeylere yoğunlaştım burada önemli
olan şey şu
e
internet benim hikayemi değiştirdi bir
krizi bir fırsata dönüştürdü bugün
kısaca internetin Nasıl beni etrafımdaki
insanları hayatını değiştirdiğini ve
toplumların hayatını
değiştirebileceğine değineceğim önce
kendi yolumdan bahsedeyim
Eee her zaman derslerim kötü değildi
başlarda iyiydi fen lisesini kazanmıştım
Erzurum Fen lisesi'de okurken Eee çok
sistemlidir her şey yani size çok güzel
net bir hikaye sunarlar dediler ki işte
tıp fakültesine gireceksin zaten 24
kişilik sınıftan 18'i Doktor oldu bizim
lisenin dediler ki tıp fakültesine
gireceksin birinci olmazsa ikinci ikinci
olmazsa üçüncü oraya giremedin mi
Eczacılık diş hekimliği O da mı olmadı
gir Bir bölüme üniversitede Profesör ol
başka bir şey yoktu onun dışında Mesela
ben elektrik elektronik mühendisliği
okuyunca arkadaşlar Hayırlısı olsun
böyle
diyorlardı ve bu yola çıktığımda şu da
belliydi yani işte olacaktım ve devamı
da tasarlanmıştı Ve pürüzsüz bir yol
vardı işte neredeyse üniversite sınavına
girerken
evleneceğim kişinin nerede yaşadığından
doğacak çocuğumu yazdıracağım okul
belliydi ve diyorlar ki işte tutmuş yol
var işte önünde onu uyg
Ama bu yola uymadım Çünkü Lisede daha
lisede okurken biraz Eee kabuğu kırmak
gerektiğini hissediyordum bu his nasıl
bir şey bilmiyorum ama hissediyordum
işte rahmetli Oktay Sinanoğlu'nun
görüşleriyle ilgili gazete çıkartmıştı
lisede ya fen lisesi öğrencisinin ne işi
olur değil mi ya Sonra işte farkındalık
kulüpleri işte zeka toplulukları falan
filan kuruyorduk bir kabuğu kıracaktı
ama nasıl kıracağım belli değil
Erzurum'dan Eee ve
şöyle bir şey gördüm bir gün lisede
duvarda bir internet sitesinin Reklamını
gördüm internet sitesini arkadaş açmıştı
şaşırdım dedim ki yani bu internet
sitesiyle
ben yan yan sınıftaki öğrenciye yan
okuldaki öğrenciye yan şehirdeki
öğrenciye ulaşacağım ve müdür bunu
kontrol edemeyecek mükemmel bir şey
dedim Yani bu aradığımız şey bu Sonra
çocuğa dedim ki bana da açar mısın tabii
dedi bir haftalık karşılığım aldı
ücretsiz site açmış Şansıma Dün Z
gelmişti arkadaş o zaman ilk internet
sitesini açtım ve internete yoğunlaştım
Eee şuraya geçmeden internete
yoğunlaştım işte kitaplar falan projeler
bir sürü yeni insan tanıdım Maddi manevi
buradan bir sürü kazanç elde ettim şu an
Hayalimdeki işte çalışıyorum ve en
önemlisi bu işi daha da
yayaba doğru şimdi ikinci kısım
etrafımdakiler hayatına internet nasıl
değiştirdi ondan bahsedeceğim Annem Bir
sınıf öğretmeni bir köy okuluna atandı
okul böyle kapanacak okullar listesine
girmişti çok kötü durumdaydı annem tek
öğretmendi 14 öğrenci vardı okula bir
şeyler yapmak istiyorduk ama dedik ki
Nasıl yapalım dedim Benim YouTube kanalı
var biliyorsun işte ben diyeyim ki ben
matematik videoları yeni çekeyim Siz de
bana kitap yollayın abonelere üçer tane
okula kitap Sonra bir video çektik
YouTube'a koyduk ve video o kadar hızlı
yayıldı ki kanaldan ve benim
Facebook'tan falan okula Biz 8.000
kitaplı bir kütüphane yaptık işte bu
konteyner var Onun dışında büyük bir
kütüphane var Türkiye'nin ilk açık hava
kütüphanesini yaptık Ondan sonra
internetten gelen yardımlarla bilgisayar
Sınıfı ve kodlama atölyesi kurduk
çocuklar Bu yıl Yapay Zeka projesi
geliştiriyor okul çok iyi bir duruma
geldi artık kolejlerden kayıtlar gelmeye
başlıyor okula Eee ve şu işte açık hava
Kütüphanesi
Eee ve Annem fark yaratan seçildi
Sabancı Vakfı tarafından Bu yıl Eee
geçen yıla da giriyor olabilir dönemi
tam Sonra dedim ki ya benim bir sürü
internet arkadaşlarım var senin bu
başarıları görüyorlar biz de bir şey
yapalım diyorlar ne yapabiliriz webiner
diye bir şey var İnternetten seminer
yapacaklar alanında uzman kişiler
çocuklara seminer yapacak Tamam yapalım
dedik bir sürü şey çıktı Yani Güney
Afrika'dan resim dersi veren bile oldu
çocuklara ve bu webinar projesiyle Eee
Annem Microsoft'un harikalar yaratan
öğretmeni seçildi ve Kanada'ya gitti
şimdi yeni Türkiye'ye geldi bu sabah çok
yeni bir olay bu da ve Eee orada temsil
etti Türkiye'yi en önemlisi Şu internet
annemin okuldaki çocukların O köy
okulundaki çocukların hayatını
değiştirdi Yakın çevremden Ailemden bir
örnek daha vereceğim e eşim evlendik
Çünkü bizim bizim jenerasyon ve
internetin tüketici tarafında olan bir
birey evlendik dedim ki İngilizce
öğretmeni teknolojiyi kullanarak birçok
şey yapabilir ve üretici tarafa geç
Sonra işte YouTube kanalı internet
sitesi mobil uygulama geliştirdi
Android'de e ve İşte bu teknoloji
üzerine kitabı yazdı bir çocuk
teknolojiyi seven bir çocuk İngilizceyi
teknolojiyle öğreniyor ve üretken tarafa
geçti ailenin dışında çok yeni Mesela
dün olan bir şey onu slayt ekleyemedim
Erzurum Fen Sesindeki çocukları bu ara
organize ediyorum ve iki tane teknoloji
dergisi çıktı okulda ücretsiz
dağıtılıyor Eee ücret bütün sponsorluğu
mezunlar karşılıyor ve dün ikinci
dergimiz dağıtıldı Çocuklar okulda bir
teknoloji dalgası oluşturmaya başladı 9
sınıf öğrencisi yapıyor Bunu sonra dedik
ki olayı büyütelim Hayalimdeki robota
başladık Her çocuğun hayalinde bir robot
vardır Ama o zamanla o robotu yapmaktan
vazgeçer ve dedik ki Hayalinizdeki
robotu anlatın çocuklar hayalindeki
robotu anlatmaya başladı biz 2 ayda 81
ile çıktık 2023 hedefi koyduk o kadar
hızlı geldi ki durduramadık 3.000 de
durdurduk videoları hala geliyor Bu
arada da yani olabildiğince kırmamaya
çalışıyoruz alıyoruz yine 81 ilen
çocuklar hayalindeki videoyu robotu
anlattı bu çocuklarla İşte 23 Nisan'da
kodlama kitapları falan yollayacağız
yine sponsorlar gönüllüler e ve 81'i de
kodlama atölyesine başlayacağız Hani
somut olarak internetin nasıl insanların
hayatını dönüştürdüğü örnekler vermek
istiyorum başta Sonra teorik kısma
geçeceğim yine İstanbul'dan bir fotoğraf
hayalindeki robotla
ilgili hayalindeki robot ekibinde çok
güzel insanlarla Tanıştık bir sürü
öğretmenle toplandık dedik ki yeni bir
şey yapalım Ali hep Ata baktı Ali artık
uzaya baksın
Eee ve Eee sonra gruptan bir kişi dedi
ki Eee ben bunu koordine edeyim NASA
tarafıyla iletişim kurayım Eee o da yine
üniversite öğrencisi nasa'daki iletişim
kurduğu ve Biz bir gün çocuklara video
çektirip Twitter üzerinden sorularını
NASA çalışanlarına yönettik bir gün
yaptık zaten etkinliği 1000e yakın soru
soruldu 5 milyon erişim aldı gönderiler
ve bir NASA çalışanı nasa'da roket
uzmanı soruları cevaplarken tkç
öğrenmeye
çalışıyor ve şu çok önemli bir şey yani
sizin milyar dolarlık markalarının
kurumlarının yapamadığı bir
şeyi Şırnaklı bir çocuk
yaptı burada duygulanımı
Biliyordum yine duygulandım beceremedim
bu çok önemli bir şey sonra şimdi
internetin soyut kısmına geçmek
istiyorum Yani asıl dünyadaki sınırları
İnternet neden değiştirebiliriz nasıl
değiştirebiliriz az bir sürem
kaldı Facebook'a İlk
girdiğimde 2007 yılında işte Ne
yazacağız arama motoruna dedik her şey
biliyor Facebook buluyor falan dedim ki
Matrix felsefesi yazayım zor bir soru
sonra yazdım ve şöyle bir şey çıktı
Matrix felsefesine inananlar grubu ve
tıklıyorsunuz katılıyorsun
Kanadalı biri var Amerikalı biri var ve
o anda hayat felsefesi üzerine saniyede
bir iletişim kurabiliyorsunuz Ben dedim
ki Hadi hayırlısı olsun yani bu dünyayı
değiştirecek bir şey çünkü hani bir Arap
baharını görmesem de toplumları çok
hızlı değiştirebilecek bir icadın sosyal
Ağar olduğunu o an fark
etmiştim ve internet burada çok önemli
çünkü o kanada'daki ile Türkiye'deki
buluşturuyor kırmızıları buluşturuyor
burada biraz kırmızı temasını kullanmak
istiyorum Ben tedx de muhtemelen
Kırmızının Bu bahsettiğim kırmızıdan
geldiğini
düşünüyorum çok az da geliyor he
matrixten sonra kırmızıdan önce bir şey
söyleyeceğim bu fotoğrafı bilen var
mı soluk Mavi Nokta mutlaka bakın
üzerine karsan'ın harika bir konuşması
var Şu nokta dünya Dünyaya en uzaktan
çekilmiş
fotoğraf şimdi bütün tarihteki savaşlar
kavgalar Bu toz zerresinin üzerinde
oldu bu toz zerresi yakından
baktığımızda iki tane rengi barındırıyor
bir griler bir de kırmızılar Yani
Google'a girip farklı insan different
person veya Arapça Bunun benzerini
arattığın da şu tarz fotoğraflar çıkıyor
Bir sürü gri bir tane
kırmızı şimdi
bu Burada şu önemli kırmızılar var
Dünyanın her yerinde her sokakta var Ben
hatta çocuk çoğunun kırmızı olduğunu
düşünüyorum Ama zamanla grileşiyor
Biz internetle bu grileşme ii nasıl
önleyebiliriz Çünkü grileşti zaman o
Matrix repliği aklıma geliyor İnsanların
çoğu sistemi o kadar Umutsuzca bağlı ki
onu korumak için
savaşacaklar şu anda bu savaşta Belki de
ilk defa top grilerin ayağından
kırmızıların ayağına
geçiyor Çünkü kanada'daki 13 yaşındaki
bir çocuk işte Manisa'daki 15 yaşındaki
bir çocukla bir oyun
yazdığında o çocuk önüne konulan
hikayeyi yapmayacak ve o çocuğu kimse
durduramayacak kırmızıların grileşmesi
nasıl önleyeceğiz Hindistanlı düşünür
çok sevdiğim krishna m'in çok önemli bir
sözü var burada yola çıkarken bakmak
için krishna murty duyan var mı
eee krn mti diyor ki insanlık Hala
eskiden olduğu gibi hala acımasız şiddet
dolu Zalim ve rekabetçi bu noktadayız
yani bilgi çağında
olabiliriz ama anlam çağına daha
geçmedik işte kırmızılar bilgi çağına
anlam çağına
taşıyacaklar şimdi Birkaç tane soru
sormak
lazım kırmızıların grileşmesi sağlayacak
internet mekanizmalarını nasıl
oluşturacağız dünyanın iki farklı
ucundaki çocuğun birbirinden nefret
etmemesini beraber üretmesini sağlayacak
interneti parmakların ucuna nasıl
getireceğiz bilgi çağını nasıl anlam
çağına dönüştüreceğiz
Teşekkür
ederim son olarak bir şey söyleyeceğim
buraya gelmeden önce bir dolaştım tane
grileşmek olan kırmızı gördüm 6 sınıf
öğrencisi onları sahneye davet etmek
istiyorum Belki biraz şeyin dışına
çıkacağım ama Beril Hazal ve
Orhan Şimdi konuştuk YouTube kanalı
açmışlar eğitimle ilgili içerikler
koymuşlar sonra kötü yorumlar geldiği
için kanalı durdurmuşlar Bugün tekrar
video çekmeye başladılar Bugün tekrar
ilk videolarını çektiler onları
[Alkış]
alkışlamanın Bugün tekrar internetin
üretici tarafına geçtiler
kırmızıların grileşmesi Onların da
grileşmesi için onların Her zaman
yanımda olduğunuzu göstermemiz gerekiyor
bir alkış daha rica ediyorum Çok
teşekkürler gelin
buradan Teşekkür ederim Gelin